[Music]
league of legends
might be one of the most popular games
on the planet but that doesn't mean
it's not full of things that make you
want to smash your keyboard to bits
the point is the game isn't perfect far
from it in fact
so today we're going to talk about the
most irritating
infuriating rage inducing aspects of the
game
that even the biggest fans of it have to
put up with but just before we jump into
that
make sure you are subscribed to the
score esports if you haven't done so
already
so you never miss a great video just
like this one and with that
let's get into the top 10 [ __ ] in
league of legends
let's just get the elephant in the room
out of the way at number 10
toxicity what is this
what the [ __ ] look we love league of
legends we do but you know that the game
has a bit of a problem when things like
this happens
now we don't have nearly enough time
here to dive into all the theories about
why league of legends can be so toxic
but as the game continues to grow
even new players are shocked by just how
poisonous the environment can be
now apparently everybody that starts a
new account has played this game and is
a god at this game
because their attitude is absolutely
disgusting
let's try and clear our heads a bit now
as we move on to our number nine
bit of [ __ ] snowballing
get over here dude we are slapping
right now oh my god this champion
if he gets going he gets going the
ability in league for some champions to
turn
a small lead into a 1v5 stomp has
played the game for years all right
i'll take the uh oh it should that was a
better
point in case for me is master yi the
veteran bladesman
is a prime example of a champion that is
equally as terrifying when winning
or losing because hey alpha strike it
will just blow up your whole team
[Music]
oh baby nice throw
let's be clear plenty of champions are
strong but giving the enemy katarina a
couple of early kills can make you call
for a forfeit before the laning phase is
even
finished now some would say that these
champions are
high risk high reward picks and that
some well-placed cc and team
coordination
can stop them in their tracks
unfortunately those are two things that
you'll rarely find in solo queue
they might be at our red for sure wait
what
you win some you lose a lot we couldn't
make this list without discussing the
thing that we're all chasing at number
eight
lp korea's solution absolutely
this solo queue i don't have a mouse so
i can't in the game
you get lp you climb up the rank ladder
but riot system adjusts the numbers
based on your mmr rating which is
supposed to be an
indication of whether you belong in your
current division
problem is a lot of players think it
fails at that
okay clearly i belong here
so why won't you give me even gay why do
i lose
19 paid 14 it should
be simple but for a long time it's been
infuriating that the lp deduction for a
loss can be straight up ridiculous
compared to the
meager gains for a win and there's even
been accusations that riot employee
accounts don't even have to put up with
this [ __ ]
and this is his lp game he loses 11
loses 11 loses 9
loses 9 gains 25 loses 9 loses 9 gains
30.
loses 7 loses 9 loses 6 gains 33
like this is why i'm saying riot
accounts aren't balanced like it sounds
so stupid
next up at number seven now we have the
blame game
like you cannot tell me this guy is a
like support
slash gold main support man and doesn't
understand the importance
of level two push and [ __ ] hitting it
first
it's hard to admit when you're wrong in
life and it's even harder to admit
you're wrong in league of legends
common sense would tell you that you're
supposed to see your teammates as
allies fighting for a common cause but
most of the time they end up being
scapegoats to blame when things don't go
your way
that's not a normal jungler match unless
i go [ __ ] help these
i don't even call them people camels you
got them
livestock in your [ __ ] lanes
at this point we've seen it all 80
carries blame support players
supports blame their 80 carries mid and
top blame each other
oh and everyone blames the jungler
next up at number six we have balancing
like she's dead too she's dead this
champion
no it's worse than zoe dude
in an effort to keep league exciting and
fresh riot often tries to tweak the game
but
they sometimes end up creating the most
headache-inducing metas imaginable
we'd be here all day listing the
balancing mistakes over the years but
some
sins really do stand out in season three
we had the armour shredding black
cleaver that could be stacked for some
ungodly reason
that was fun the 2015 juggernaut
disaster
broke champions like skarner darius and
moore to the point where they
ruined solo q and pro play they gotta be
careful
a big knockback and that's the kill in
the morgana azir goes down as well but
the dunks are coming through
a double kill for a balls a triple kill
holy
and who can forget the time when a riot
employee hit back a criticism of their
balancing by saying
they're actually right because they have
200 plus collective years of
professional game design
experience whatever that means and
usually
just when you think things are starting
to settle down riot releases
a new champion that is more often than
not bone shakingly broken
one word for you a felios it's one free
kill waiting for me
mr jin
[Laughter]
when i die i want n a teams to lower me
into the ground so they can let me down
one last time so our number five spot
goes to m a
at international events just as our
region
is weak you know it's just it's just
weak chances are
a lot of you watching are from na if
you're from eu
well then congrats you're from a region
which consistently gives
china and korea a run for their money
but for na fans
it's been 10 years now of mind-numbing
disappointment
league was made in n a and they showed
it to the world and in return
na has become the laughingstock of
international pro-play
and every year after n a inevitably gets
slapped around at worlds people try to
answer one of the game's age-old
questions why is n a so
dog [ __ ] it could be server population
it could be the academy system
failing to develop new talent or it
could just be written
into the laws of the universe the na is
destined to give their fans
just enough hope to then crush their
dreams forever
or at least until the next year the
title flag doublelift is dead again he's
been seen grayscale
for the last four minutes there's
nothing he can do
there's nothing team liquid can do and
invictus
gaming will be eliminating the third
and final lcs contender from world
invictus gaming
advanced to the quarter-finals
moving on to number four we have
smurfing get this
you can make an extra account for free
and
intentionally grief your games until
you're low enough elo
to play against people who are way below
your skill level
wow doesn't that sound amazing smurfing
is pretty
rampant in league of legends now whether
you're new to the game or just an
average player
you can expect to play with or against
smurfs who just suck
all of the fun out of league by getting
28 kills in as many minutes
i am always fighting people who are
above my skill level
or people who are way below there is
rarely a closed game
it doesn't matter whether they buy their
smurf accounts or just
tank their accounts in ranked it's
literally anti-fun to play against them
but people kind of forget this when
they're not the ones getting digger
stomped which is why almost
every league streamer seems to have done
an unranked
challenger series by now which is
essentially smurfing on steroids
i have 30 goals god damn
next up at number three now we have new
champions
like i don't know bro and it's all every
new champion is
so absurdly broken it's pretty much
expected now that new champions in
league will probably have the most
busted broken ass kits when compared to
older champions
somewhere along the line riot decided
that every new champion
needs to be more complex and over tuned
than the last
[ __ ] dashes six times she's stealth
now this wouldn't matter so much if
league was full of only those champions
if everyone's super then nobody is right
but the problem is you've got champions
like
vigo whose main gimmick is being able to
literally
morph into any other champion once he
kills them which is
pretty broken okay can anybody explain
what is this guy doing it's [ __ ]
slammed
it's so broken and that champion sits
alongside the
decade old uday whose playstyle has
never evolved past
running and slapping
open your wallets nice and wide now for
at number two because we're talking
about the
ridiculous price of skins look
we all love skins and league does have
some pretty great ones
but 25 bucks for the likes of spirit
guardian ud
really he's essentially just shirtless
with some slightly cooler stance effects
as someone who actually owns this skin
even i have my regrets
when pulse ezreal was released in 2012
it was so much better than other skins
that you could almost forgive the price
tag
but it's still 25 despite looking
extremely average by today's standards
magnificent tf is an absolute scam i'm
sorry
ten dollars to basically give him a top
hat and a red jacket
who is even buying this after 11 years
and don't get me started on the prestige
skins which require you shelling out for
special passes and
tokens despite them being essentially
just white recolorings
all we ever get is paid babble passes
and skins
skins skin
and finally now the biggest [ __ ] in
league of legends at number one
we have yasuo mains yasuo syndrome is
best defined as an untreatable disease
that does major damage to a human
central nervous system namely the
frontal lobe of the brain that controls
judgment which results in sporadic acts
of greed stupidity
and hostility while you may have
disagreed with some of the other entries
on this list
the one thing that the entirety of
league's fractured community can agree
on
is that yasuo means just suck to be
clear
yasuo is a fine champion no problem with
him really but the players that are
drawn to him
seem to have made a deal with the devil
they either get 20 kills or 20 deaths
it's a total coin flip as to which one
they'll be
you see it's very easy to become a yasuo
main all it takes is one game see what
you do is you go to lane and then you
you die
once uh then a second time make sure you
let your team know that you don't need
any assistance now you might think oh
well maybe the yasuo
main that feeds 20 kills will be on the
enemy team
but no that's never how it works somehow
the enemy yasuo is always the one
sliding effortlessly around
team fights and pulling off insane olds
to carry his team
and your yasuo will without fail be the
one
sliding through a minion wave to his
death or ulting that which should never
be altered
the win dick gets in a fierce battle
with bambi and decides to take a break
from dashing just so she can bash that
heath and then he continues with his
long-winded strategy to win this fight
and you just know that somewhere there's
a village missing its idiot and i am
pretty sure we have found him as he
proceeds to dash around like a clueless
dog during a thunderstorm
and if this reputation wasn't bad enough
yasuo
mains are also known for being shall we
say a little on the angry side
i'm losing my mind playing with silver
players man
all right guys that's enough [ __ ]
for today did i miss anything out that
really pisses you off in league
which other games [ __ ] should we do
a top 10 list on next
let me know thanks for watching and i'll
see you all in the next one
auto attack something man shut the [ __ ]
up
shut the [ __ ] up i'm trying my best
you missed everything else shut up shut
up you [ __ ] apple
i tried my best does that mean